[Music]
hello hello everybody yeah it breaking
the news day everything's all better
perfect perfect what is up everybody
okay I made the lighting like a little
bit darker than usual I was gonna say
this was a commuter mug oh no we're
definitely showing spirit yes exactly so
I've concocted this whole plan so that
for the next eight extreme days not
including community Fridays we're gonna
be playing some spooky games until
Halloween I've decided to call it eight
days of horror and I went on Twitter and
I was like hey friends tell me your
eight favorite scary games which in
hindsight I'm like man that's a lot of
games yeah but you guys showed up you
guys definitely gave me a ton of things
to look into to choose from so we're
kicking it off with some Silent Hill -
oh yeah today and this is the HD
collection now I've never played any of
the Silent Hill games I've only recently
have been like enjoying scary games more
because I'm a huge chicken but lately
they've been kind of more fun to me even
though I get scared it's still a great
time so hello everybody I'm ready to
embark on to this world I'm gonna go
with the new voice I'd say go for it
original the HD collections got a wild
history of what things that have gone on
with it there's oh people might be able
to keep me up on this but I think
specifically the PlayStation version got
a patch so it had a whole bunch of stuff
that kind of fixed it because it was
kind of not great at first I see ah and
the Xbox version just got like a patch
left completely out of it just because
they're like Oh Silent Hill is a
PlayStation series so it only gets the
updates to make it better I see I see
okay so I'm the main one yeah oh man so
many choices interesting let's start
with normal on both cuz I feel pretty
normal I guess
that's right I like normal is the
difficult because it's it's what the
developers intended to be like the
basement
yeah this is my face I'm me
same great word
oh my am i okay thought this was like
tricky camera England got a walk thing
or something
you know your games great when it starts
out in a gross bath
yes hello everyone well cover could you
really be in this town via the yard
the main thing for the HD collection was
I think the original like files for the
games were all lost and the build that
the people got to do the HD version was
like a like an uncomplete like like 89%
of the way their build and they had to
try to build the rest of the game to
make it work it's like volume leveling
is kind of weird and stuff but Matt
snake brings up the the point that I was
trying to get at I think a lot of people
still think the ps2 version is like the
pure like if you want Silent Hill that's
that's the way to do it all right so I'm
just suggesting here and so the controls
of its it's got those does take take
good times yes it's like the deef has
like walk forward you actually have to
press fo right even your fear not like
facing that way so I was like wait
what's happening here alright so I have
like this power stance yeah yeah that's
that's when you're getting ready to
fight off the ghosts and demons that
come after you so I'm gonna get right
out in front of this yes I I pride
myself on at least playing or seeing as
many games as I can I've never actually
played Silent Hill 2
but it was one of those games that I saw
on my dad play fair he was more into
like the scary stuff and he's like check
out this Silent Hill game it's real real
wacky he also introduced me to resident
evil which I was more of a resident evil
person than the Silent Hill person
you're a pro at that when we were
playing that last time I love Resident
Evil so much I also like Silent Hill
since the HD version wasn't like the
best way to go about it I never got
around to priceless dreams but I still
want to play it I see that down so I
wanna get that proper remake I'm Sean
yeah he's here actually the movie the
first movie released actually pretty
good too don't read it I'm reading
everything venom I'm literally reading
your message right now literally reading
[Music]
our stream buffer is actually really
long - I got a letter oh snap the name
on the envelope
said Mary hey so chilled my wife's me
Sammy all you guys how you doing
well calculus hope we're gonna a great
Monday couldn't possibly be true that's
what I keep telling myself did person
can't write a letter oh this got deep
already Mary died of that damn disease
every daily disease so then why am I
looking for her could she be Taco Bell
Oh snatch that is a special special it
really is does she mean the park on the
lake we spent the whole day there just
the two of us it's not as bad the feels
so I really be there you should play
through the whole game if you get the
chance so there's different endings and
it's interesting what they kind of do
with waiting for me everything in this
game this game in particular yeah
alright let's walk HD collection or
original this is the HD collection to be
just cuz it was it was easier to kind of
get going
it is the PlayStation version though so
it's got like the updates to make it a
little bit a little better we're playing
with the original voices too so that's
also good I can't get in the car yet
let's walk more
it's got taking the scenery
I was so long ago that I forget when
this game came out I think 2001 is said
yeah oh there's a map in the guy she
thinks it's feel so inverted like this I
got this that's supposed to make you
feel scared not emotional hey man I know
being scared as an emotion technically
it's setting me up for failure
yeah the fog is different the textures
are kind of bumped up it's it's weird
looking at the HD collection success now
I can press this button and something
will happen
ah the town
Coop's there's the park right there yeah
that's where we want to go head along
Nathan Avenue this is my first time
playing this so uh I've only recently
found out that although I get super
scared I actually enjoy scary games this
is a recent discovery for me so what
what do you know about Silent Hill
already going in like TV seem like any
of the monsters or like have an idea of
how structurally works on them I've seen
some of the monsters like the triangle
head dude but I really don't know much
about the story and then I've played
like the PT Josh I don't even know how
closely related that is to the rest of
this look that's pretty good then you'll
be able to kind of experience stuff
figuring it out as you're going which is
good it's very foggy Oh
remember if the original was as film
grainy as this she's heard noises
so it starts those York crashing his car
in the forests everything's fine I'm
actually playing this off I was like the
PS now screaming which is like really
convenient so I was like man I'm
I wonder how difficult is gonna be to
get this game it's like streaming right
now boom I was like oh thanks it's
actually pretty impressive considering
like how there's fog everywhere and
that's the type of thing that messes up
like grates on stuff and it's still kind
of like it's not messing up too bad yeah
it's very foggy I don't even know if
this map was like useful I can't see
where I am play re 7 + vr re7 in VR
didn't really give me that much are you
sevens great though
try think the last game that that kind
of scared me and I feel like it might
have been PT those are the sounds
yeah you talkin a lot of people coming
in saying the best way to play is the
original game on the PlayStation 2 for
sure
but sometimes you got to go with ease of
access yeah it's a it's a bit it's a bit
quicker
you know what this game really love Mary
because I would have done ran would not
not spend as much time walking around in
here he used to try to remember
[Music]
like this map where am I Oh my lawyer my
wife oh no I think you can run with oh
well well hmm
sure let's explore what's that yeah this
makes me feel like some someone's
growing your love gives me a weird oh no
I shouldn't that's scary so we're off to
a good start saving the games are really
scary that's how you know it's it's a
real situation I love the shot of him
just like looking okay so I saved the
world
Bob Jones and Lazarus both calling
coming out on saying how quickly you'd
abandon your your friends asking if
you'd actually leave Mary that quickly I
mean he said she was already dead true
so part of me is like that damn disease
oh yeah Oh while it's true that the HD
version isn't great Nathan you you can't
really like get too upset it the people
who've made it because it's [ __ ] Konami
there you go that's the button cuz
Konami lost the original builds and then
the poor people who got tasked is making
the HD version had to try and make an
entire game where there wasn't any and
did the best with what they had
[Music]
yes excuse me I'm sorry me I thought
it's okay I didn't mean to scare you I'm
kind of lost lost in this fog yeah I'm
looking for a silent hill is this the
right way yeah it's hard to see with
this fog there's only the one road you
can't miss it
Thanks would you guys ever go to Silent
Hill if it existed just say yes I'll let
you know after it was game this this
town there's something wrong is it
dangerous
and it's not just the mob either okay I
got it I'll be careful
I'm not lying no I believe you
it's just I don't care if it's dangerous
or not this is the og boys town either
huh we had to go with the original I I
insisted yes yes I'm looking for some
someone
who is it someone
very important to me I'd do anything if
I could be with her again I mean my
mother it's been so long since I've seen
her
I thought my father and brother were
here but I can't go home either so
that's that's the other thing that
happened with me always HD remakes is
they increase the frame rate so it
causes all tio Q's and original dialogue
to be off which is why they had to
rerecord most of it and now that gave us
the option of having the original voices
or the redone ones to be able to follow
those cues and the music sometimes has
to loop over or starts or changes yeah I
know I said a little bit and um like
even the menu screen all right back to
creepy lady running into the
I'll be a it again it goes without
saying the best way to play this if
anyone wants to is definitely ps2 it's
probably best to avoid the HD versions
but the convenience of being able to
stream it is pretty good yeah it was
convenient cuz I didn't have to like
download the whole file
you were almost to Jill sandwich
Errol's got my girl's got my back well
we've got eight whole days I'm gonna try
to play as many of the scary games that
we all love or that you guys love field
frame will be really fun
that was a pot another popular one on
there which but there's a few versions
which would you recommend friends to -
yeah me too
Fatal Frame 2 still scares me even now I
don't get scared very easily but two is
definitely a heck of a time
thank them captain free video games as
awesome GameSpot yeah I mean I always
hear so much Silent Hill 2 is not scary
at all play Silent Hill 4 see the real
fear whoo he's got a little ghost emoji
there to keep out that much me and I'm
going in that form
through many games on Halloween
Halloween on a weekday it's on Thursday
oh yeah that's nice yeah we would be
would be in a weird place if we didn't
do a scary game or stream on Halloween
yeah that's kind of what these spooky
streams are gonna be like celebration
lead up to it I kind of wanted to play
Pete Eve I have played it a few times I
know I have to find someone who's never
played it for it to be more exciting to
watch fail frame 1 2 & 3 are awesome I
heard the Wii version is good the Wii
version was was interesting I liked the
implementation of like the tablet to do
stuff but feel free to is like the one
that I always think about like that one
a lot oh man he was
this is when a lot of running around
Lauren is free now oh I went for a big
run
yeah filly Prince I agree silent hill's
probably would have been too much if if
PT alone was that that strong of an
experience like whole game would be so
much oh we just mansions out the
spookiest game oh snap
I hope this isn't Chris's blood
someone's trying to get my car it's fine
I was supposed to go this way but I'm
gonna get got to find the scariest game
out there so we could stream and it's
true we got like we got a crowdsource we
got it we got to do polls we got to do
science wow this guy he was like that
shadow scared yeah I'm gonna run towards
it I mean you gotta check it out
Taiyo go I hope I said your name right
if I didn't please let me know but they
asked who plays all the Silent Hill
games this is purchase first Silent Hill
experience and I've only watched most of
Silent Hill being played by my dad so
I'm continuing the tradition by watching
it being played again eventually I'll
play it you see I need like a good if
the HD version was done better I
probably wouldn't but it's need to find
time to do it I was more of a Resident
Evil guy - I want to oh the road it's
gone good thing I they really want me to
follow these blood tracks see in real
life I would never be able to someone
try to get into a car with no arms
perfectly normal yeah it's fine Lazarus
it's okay
I wish I was there some way that kind of
like get Petey back I still have like
the the broken install on on my ps4 just
happens me every time I check so can't
do it can't ever do it again
[Applause]
some dangerous nonsense maybe I'm I
turned I'm just to like to be safe so no
sometimes it gets it gets loud small I
walk the damn mgs3 Pacheco I want them
to take those engines done in the or the
the cutscenes on the Fox engine and give
me a Metal Gear Solid 3 remake with them
any time I think about things next few
waiting over there it's okay
he's a cool dude
we have no weapons weird
oh yeah if you if people who are
watching you don't know
the radio static means that there's
something scary close to you ready
stance oh boy oh boy
right this block got a wacom how do I am
black and oh there oh you're there you
got it you got it yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah all right in the legs got him all
right
nailed it Wood now to protect this check
my map I look to see a lot of horror
games get the re to treatment for sure
Kevin free video games res evil - was
it's the perfect mix of everything that
Resident Evil needed to come back to
what it needed to be it's it's wonderful
alright let's get out of here my piece
of wood oh yeah
just like broken
[Music]
mmm loud and clear can you hear me now I
better take it anyway yeah I'm gonna say
you're gonna need it
oh yes go girls small for the switch
tomorrow yes it's going down wait my
foot yeah some sweet footprints going on
okay so I'll try to make it to rose
water park yeah that original concept
for re4 was also really cool because it
was kind of like like you Dame over your
shoulder but you'd have the fixed camera
angles when walking around I'd be
curious to see how that would have
worked yeah that pyramid had seen last I
heard it wasn't it wasn't in the game I
think like I remember there being
something about it being taken out an HD
version not sure and I know you guys
know better than I do
more of them yes this is the the ps3
version updated but still the HD version
oh my god you're right slapping it yeah
oh okay wait hold up but that wasn't no
now you need to be dead
you know it you got it bro I don't know
[Applause]
he's getting up
he's back really good at getting back up
for not having arms I know that's a
skill just like die for all the time
okay the static is gone
I'm surprised that there aren't more
Silent Hill games on Steam - James I
feel like that'd be a good place to put
them so basically those two roads were
blocked off so I'm gonna find the new
way and I'm down to cat Street capcom
would probably do a really good job with
also I love that Capcom is looking at
bringing back other old so like give me
some some beautiful Joe or hit me up
with like Power Stone yeah they're doing
a pretty good job with the they brought
out like the HD collection recently yeah
more fingers right is never a bad thing
right up past big J's take a right let's
see if we can go up that way how closely
related is part one what's the past not
in a prowling parasite eve would be a
good one to bring back to we're supposed
to be getting like a me
meet them I've been waiting on that I
love here effect no there's too many of
them
pastor tower should be back to course C
Capcom make half-life 1 C PlatinumGames
make half-life well Gordon Freeman
jetting around take super long way it's
how you find your way around so you
gotta you gotta see everything there's
the C oh man also while we've got all
you guys here it's definitely a good
time to do cool promo type thing
of course we stream every weekday at 11
a.m. Pacific Life this week you guys
should stick around over the weekend cuz
we're doing extra life starting on
Friday middle a day all the way through
a whole weekend you playing games
raising money for charity and you can
all be part of it and we hope that
you'll join us yeah okay so I was
blocked off to try heading through one
of the buildings
I think the restroom
oh boy the buildings you thing says no
trespassing I wouldn't do it definitely
squished a bug - ooh Dino Crisis or dot
flipping sign me up for that shame
they're only two of those games should I
go down Neely Street I check out the
restaurant though starting normal stream
I think it's starting at noon if I'm
there you go
it says closed there's also a medkit
down there on the ground med kids are
always good I'm a big fan of cool okay
Daniel Daniel's saying the apartment
gate behind us okay I'm down I'm down
for hints on where to go cuz yes
your boy doesn't remember side
apartments Blue Creek apartment yes
probably up that way
yes we're talking about so chilled kappa
i'm bringing you back all the IPS and i
i'm i'm a double down I want power stone
like even if it's just an HD remake of
like one and two or like a port of the
Vita version or the PSP version I'm into
it alright thanks for 7 by captain video
games enjoy your your attack on Titan
game I hope you have a good day aha no
one over there I know he's walking over
to me I think ya know the ps3 version
did get that patch it's still really
weird the xbox version got left out oh
no I'm stuck here Thank You Brad ah okay
men don't like this yeah it's still not
anyone here alright there we go it's
turning the camera
oh and an overhead attack come on now
look at them dancing how dare you
disrespect me oh I do I think it's a
wait I thought it was one I really I
think the diner was the first Silent
Hill so I remember I remember going into
it and you you get like a gun
[Applause]
all right maybe I have to overhead chop
that locker it's a break I don't think
my little side chops are working okay
[Music]
great twos or I'm guessing that you
probably you me and my two by fours but
yeah what's the Dodge button Bob Jones
those bobs go to advice for everything
[Applause]
how do I do that overhead shot up last
time whoo all right yeah let's go search
for this key cuz clearly my 2x4 is not
strong enough good if I have those
things bearing down on me I don't find a
way to make up two by four words where
did we not look at yet do go does
confirm key time gotta find the key yeah
Keith I'm Keith I was 18 when this first
came out my memory on Silent Hill 2 is
still fuzzy dude I feel you I didn't
even play it so my memories like double
fuzzy because any time I'd see it was
just me coming into the room and be like
oh what's going on now I'm going to
assume we're going in the right
direction the public key is found beside
a corpse in the north side of Martin
Street in the south
I did see a corpse earlier daniel has
got that then hot walk through time
Thank You Daniel noise wait where I
think that was straight ahead actually
by the church what is it so yeah go up
march street which is to the right and
then yes okay it's 15 I don't remember
squat it it's weird it's been a long
time since this games come out here st.
2001
yes scary alleyway let's go wait for
that dead body to happen hello there you
go was the my favorite thing from Silent
Hill 1 is that can you expect a doghouse
there might be dogs around okay I got
thank you we are scam on PC now I wish
it were on PC I know if the HD
collection we're on PC I'd probably get
it just because people might fix it the
rest of the way yeah it doesn't mod
sorry community wants yeah still I feel
bad for the people who had to make it
because that couldn't have been an easy
thing for them and to get something out
the door that works and runs like it
does is pretty intense September 24th
2001 turns 18 around or turned 18 around
a month ago old enough to drink silent
you do it stop it
he's just scooting having a good time Oh
missed the turn
oh wait the other door right getting the
apartment figured scene from Silent Hill
one was the opening with the body on the
page vaguely remember that - I hope this
pauses is there is a PC version of the
original I was based off the OG xbox
that it might not need to fix him to
know that it's either the room or
downpours on Steam one of those it might
be down for
oh yeah you're right my country's uh it
didn't old enough to drink not here in
the US though it's a good point don't
don't drink if you're too young
it's so foggy I keep thinking I'm making
the wrong turn that's the effect the
points you're making Silent Hill 2 I
wish but even even if they were remaking
Silent Hill 2 they'd probably have to go
off of what's already been done in these
HD versions to do it
so John Johnny tsunamis got my back oh
man why is gonna be over here okay I'll
just room stay on the channel or they
gone by the industry they uh they stick
around depending we might set them
private just to kind of make room for
other things but then they come back
later on but usually they stick around
oh my goodness I'm so struggling with
just walking straight ten controls are
kind of a wacky thing it takes some
getting used to i they remade or with
the the HD version of remake and also
the pre-release at Grim Fandango they
put in alternate controls and I still
prefer ten controls over them this just
makes me feel like I have more control
or maybe I'm just down to put up with it
what you guys think about project
resistance we actually streamed it that
stream is still up if anyone wants to
check it out it's like an hour and a
half
of just giving impressions but I enjoyed
it more than I thought I would which is
weird because I kind of was in the same
boat as everyone when they finally
showed gameplay for it like what the
heck is this but like as a side thing
like it could be pretty fun and I
there's also a part of me that loves
like trolling people so being able to
play is the mastermind and just make
people's lives more difficult was a lot
of fun
iceworm a good person yeah weird I tried
to go into this one at first it didn't
work Oh scary room okay hmm it's real
dark in here it's not foggy anymore is
that my heart rate that I'm feeling in
the vibration of this because my heart
is beating I feel the controller
vibrating oh it's real dark let's try
this door it's locked
well I gotta find a key breaking and
entering
I guess there was no breaking we stole
this key off a dead body fair and square
it's true he wasn't gonna be using I
hear some shuffling it's it's these kind
of games where you kind of like breathe
a sigh of relief when a doors off yeah
she's like I really want to go in there
anyway but okay so my left sugar kind of
changes the camera back crying low key
your name describes exactly how I feel
when I think about silent because I also
wish they would have went through with
this
[Music]
a horror game mr. Kojima del Toro juji
you know was involved in it I think at
some point like uh it would have been so
good HP I am sorry to say it is the HD
collection but it's the PlayStation one
that's been patched which is kind of
like a middle ground at least I was just
checking random rooms sure that's a good
call
Diego says our boy likes to look at
things that he can interact with there's
to scare you it did make but you know
what that means
okay that was just more startling than
anything else it's impossible to skip
leg day when you're entirely composed of
legs now you're barely middle done it uh
it's it's something though okay so I
have a flashlight now will this yes the
slashing we should be available later if
anyone wants to come back and check it
out
and also if you like scary games should
keep coming back because we're gonna be
playing a whole bunch of them the next
couple of days it'll be a good time and
if you have any scary games that you'd
recommend you should definitely mention
them indeed indeed I feel like I missed
something in your last act how's it
going pal good to see you
all right wait I'll do the tour I don't
know which way I came in I think yeah
keep kind of poking around see what's
going on I can't get the door open
Oh party over there everyone's hanging
now just gonna go in this door I didn't
like how slowly that Oh Oh see you've
come into my room may I offer you
something to drink
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
was that the last breath I could have
withstood yeah how unfortunate and then
because it's one of those games she sent
all the way back for the last time you
see well oh but it's okay though because
now you know exactly where to go with
everything
and we can skip the cutscenes that's the
nature of all these go I still love that
uh resident evil 3 it plays the intro
every time you you die and come back so
you get this like really intense like
reminder oh yeah nemesis is really gross
and he's in the game and I hate him hate
nemesis a lot alright
Wow bummer okay I just came back from
school 20 minutes ago oh hi welcome
welcome back Roberto it's good to see
you I hope you had a good time at school
doing doing some good learning what
happened we got breathe on he's got
tired and took a nap and the last time
that a safe happened was he like
while ago I totally forgot that I should
be looking for save points this is this
is what you get to practice those
speedrun technology yeah saving saving
time you know you say that the game was
scary back then snow snow snow dome hope
I said that right
uh it's still scary now kind of I
haven't I haven't gotten too surprised
by anything yet because I still think
Lea remember like oh yeah going in the
room the thing happens but yeah clock I
really want to play clock tower because
that was another one that I ended up
watching get played to I don't play a
lot of scary games when I was a kid I'd
watch my dad do it and I'm kind of sad
that the only one I picked up was
Resident Evil it might be because it's
kind of silly too yeah like Legman yeah
if have you heard about some of the
weird like items and and joke endings
you can get in these games I had I did
hear that there were a lot of different
endings but it was one very very good
joke ending for this video game I I feel
like I feel like you need to know about
it's very good do it spoil it I'm ready
wait what about Chinese I don't know how
many of you probably know probably
mention it anyway put I'll just link it
to you later yeah so you can just watch
it and see it but it's real good
schools going good so these live streams
keep up the good work oh thanks Roberto
Thanks
appreciate it no I was debating earlier
if I should have like played a little
bit at the beginning you wanted to keep
it all but yeah for the stream you want
to save it
I wanted the freshness alone in the dark
that I I played more of the 360 version
of alone in the dark which is not it's
not bad but I've heard that the original
is much better but I really enjoyed what
I plated that the kinda like the idea of
like swinging around weapons with the
stick was also kind of cool smoogle
knows I'm talking about all right yeah
yeah wait that I have my stick at this
point I think I forgot to go get the
stick and a little radio thing or was
that over here
Smilodon is also talking about Fatal
Frame 2 we were talking about that
earlier
that should definitely be one that we
hit up because I know it's on you can
play it on a ps3 oh nice I mean I'm
pretty sure I even own it that's that's
good too
it's all there you know good work thanks
Scott I know you guys are super super
nice today I know what a great way to
start the week it's it's it's scary
games bring everyone together yeah yeah
exactly
they all go out of the way to make you
feel isolated and vulnerable and we've
all got to come together to not feel as
scared my stick I feel like I cannot do
this without mistake it's very important
to have a stick for sure yeah getting
like a another remake of this probably
be a real good thing move in get the
money now it's dead where is it
see this one didn't start running around
so later when I ran into that one s
crawling I was like oh I don't know all
right
equipped get getting upgraded we're here
gang we're used to the controls use good
news
go get the key remake of fatal frame to
would probably make me cry actually that
it's our familiar with what fatal frame
kind of does know so the idea behind it
is you you're in like Japan and you have
this your only weapon is a camera so the
whole idea basically behind like what
makes it scary is that it forces you to
look at the things that are coming at
you shots of them to do damage so
basically the whole time you're looking
at the things that are scary in the
middle of your screen getting really big
in its yeah we gotta believe Alan it's
it's real real clever because a lot of
scary games you try to avoid and not
look at the things that make you brave
but here's a game that forces you to
[Music]
yeah 200% that's awesome the I don't
know why I had a shooter game in my gosh
this guy
there's a another game that is kind of a
shooter a first-person game that I
played a long time ago called cryostasis
that like not a lot of people have heard
of but like it you know about over
dinner at all it's a lot of people are
playing that recently but so the idea of
oh burden is like you go to the ship and
you have to recreate but cryostasis did
it like 12 years before and you
basically go to this icebreaker that's
been abandoned in the middle of like the
Arctic and you're crawling around on it
and you have to go and like touch these
frozen bodies and live out their last
minutes to like find out what happened
and as you do it you figure out that
there's something weird going on on the
ship and it's not what it should be
there's a lot of just like any if you're
scared of like boats or water or like
like people who think about like
swimming out in the middle of the ocean
and getting scared it's not but it's
really cool I like it a lot
let's see some people have played
cryostasis or cryostasis in the chat
Marius is coming back
mmm yes this is it's like addressing the
gate he also had a lot of really cool
tech in that where they were like let's
actually put liquid physics in a game so
when ice melts it like flows like actual
water down but yeah I'd like to play
clock tower a lot the clock tower sounds
like it'd be a hundred percent my jam
try thinking other other cool scary
games I think that might be why I like
feel free to as much as I do movies
because it's kind of broken off doesn't
really play horror games that's fine I
know it's not a thing for a lot of
people Orsino what's gonna happen no
luck days gonna pop up it's gonna be a
thing oh my gosh I walked too far like I
don't wanna yeah get the thing
flashlight brow come on he's gonna look
he's got to address here we go oh listen
[Applause]
stay down all the wiggling that was the
thing that especially like watching
Silent Hill as much as I didn't like the
the way things like like jitter around
and shake is really like the most
off-putting part yeah
Varian excuse me you're dead space was
real scary the original one top top
scary games
[Music]
okay so should save the game that is
definitely good yeah we're doing
I need a well right is that the only
place I can see it again no I think you
need the wall flashlights on we got
pictures precious memories stopping
enemies is a good call that is
definitely a thing I think you got to
find a thing to interact with all right
we must go yeah dead dead space was good
too is still pretty scary didn't get me
as much as one did three had interesting
ideas but wasn't as scary music any time
I see one of those closets like that
yeah everything when I want to say dead
space 3 had some interesting ideas just
the coop like people seeing things that
the other player doesn't see was really
interesting with that other than that it
was just kind of like a weird co-op Lost
Planet game too much action so Red
Square downstairs mobile is trying to
recall just gotta head down okay cool
made it back to the stairs
he said downstairs right yeah I wear
silent hill's didn't die to Santa Hills
would have been really good downstairs
at the entrance died ago is also saying
so right there yeah on the wall okay so
any a little red square oh wow and I
didn't even like really say the last one
huh well we did this time we get alright
so we got the flashlight we have her
stick I already beat up like man I'm
gonna go up to the third floor right now
I mean I'm still trying to get some rose
water it's the end goal here
I believe so you got to make it to that
spot that place the special please
alright I see looking on the side like
that there's interesting stuff to look
at you know it's
here's something over here is looking on
the floor yeah making a coop doesn't
seem to be you you definitely want to
pick it up Wow gotcha what an ass that's
messed up
Mikey all right so I guess we gotta go
around or something it's true I do miss
having to find things on your own and
information being freely available now
is kind of a weird deal fluid having
like the guides like the printed out
guides and stuff was like a crazy thing
I still remember away Brady guides yeah
flip it being the person at school who
had the guide for like a game everyone
was playing people would come up be like
yo you hear about this crazy thing like
yeah yeah I already know about it I got
it it's in the book I've got this this
knowledge unlock
[Music]
rat they are making a silent language
chinko that they just announced it it's
on the way would be way more useful and
aha
I've got a handgun what do you think
about dying light
I like dying light it was a fun game to
play I feel like it was a better version
of Dead Island because it's it's very
similar to that but you had the
freerunning yeah I I liked it was a good
time
the newest one you get to play with your
pals which is pretty cool play three
pals and all of them but yeah why is she
doing in here chicken keys that's what
thing do I remember drawing up maps like
noting things on them like that kind of
stuff coming from playing like old PC
adventure like pointing click 'add
pointing click adventure games like
that's probably what that key is for
bringing up puzzle solutions alright so
I'm assuming I have to find a way around
that gates to get the key to go to the
first floor must be some around the
second floor I can get up there from
possibly know I know the map doesn't
show since I'm yeah outside area okay
don't think I went don't do that what
was that some kind of noise north of
here
follow it obviously that's what you do
when you hear the noise I was like wait
I didn't activate that
looks like it's broken
everything's broken in here okay
sometimes the doors north of here
clearly didn't run north it must be
let's check all the doors check
everything Dora that was concreted up
that's not great she's got really breath
you all I was staring for wall there for
a second okay this is this must be north
I hope I wouldn't say that all new
horror games are our wack like obviously
like it's our friend Wade then I have a
gun I wouldn't waste him
but uh yeah it changes innovation or
kind of a weird thing but there are a
lot of really cool horror games out
there now not really good like indie
ones and stuff that are genuinely really
great experiences even with conveniences
put in
okay
Oh oh boy
do we do it do we just you're just scoop
towards TV so hard that you just that
guys looking over here well there's a
key give me that you know the dead body
right there - OH - that was oddly
specific hmm what's going on here
I know these camera angles the scars
from the past something remove the nail
that stops time these decisions do you
push the clock it'll push back I pitched
in but in real life I wouldn't but it oh
it's too heavy for us anyways all right
I'd say that was a success
oh there's something I'm worried there
no Henry Mildred this Scott
all right noted home way better be in
his chair when I like iron I don't think
he's moving
yeah I don't I don't want to go over
there anyways you go check the kitchen
now but have the key to - OH - that's
true
and he's gone isn't he ha
that's not funny it's cruel all right so
- OH - most sounds are already happy now
it's not doing the lock it's broken
um let's see yeah that alien game was
pretty good came out a couple of years
ago Oh three that's - OH - plot twist
need a bit more to it so probe that tore
the neck looking to a5 or 206 don't
think we've been in here though oh sure
that's oh yeah we the sewer we got the
flashlight oh no oh look I just like
lackluster attack that's just like oh
wow alright so - as he was down here
officially
oh good juice oh no here we go my
horrible no no just get in there man
Millie whoo
okay so we had a key for this place it
doesn't exactly make me feel any better
just gonna clean there's nothing inside
the cage not yet I know never say never
open scary door oh man this camera
angles are so cruel
what is that it's getting louder
no is it in this but nothing else is of
interest you don't hear that it's
probably that hole
no yes you said no but just I guess I
guess gonna stick your hand in wave
goodbye your your arm yeah something
touched me you're going again yeah
controllers vibrating my hands are
sweaty the clock key something's in here
oh thank goodness
okay I I did it though all right sound
like a gate over the bathroom yeah try
keep people out
all right let's go unlock the clock it
was next to the concrete yeah as a way
back I think no no no or was it down
that hole I think it was this way I'm
not sure though
remember short-term memory loss damage
right now I didn't go back back had some
work to do what'd I miss
not too much we've got a key for the
clock now we're headed back to the clock
room for some more dudes crawling out in
the hallways come on Ernest I was like
this hallways here it may be this this
is it yeah okay
and the clock
yeah yeah oh we did see Pyramid Head
once uh yeah he was being creepy the
other side of a gate and then he
disappear it's kind of hanging out Oh
11:29 and 15 seconds oh wait I don't
know what time I'm supposed to change it
wait I have a key you have to use it
from your inventory
oh I remember if because there's there's
a point in time where every game had
like use it from your inventory as a
thing and then everyone's like now
that's actually too much you'd have to
do it for there you go click what would
I do without Ben
you'd be sitting here looking at a clock
it's all good oh I did not know what
time I was supposed to change this you
could poke around some more for whatever
time to lose all right need some clues
what time is it it's time where would I
find I didn't examine dead man over here
there are people in the chat who threw
the time up I don't know if we want to
do that it's up to you I mean for the
sake of our last 15 minutes you just
want to hit yes
spill the beans chat and rule just nine
ten nine ten and fifteen seconds that's
the sound okay I think you should be
good to push it yeah oh snap okay I'm
excited but I'm also like oh oh that's
my shadow oh dang yeah I was scared
thanks chat we're now and oh this must
be towards the other side of my creepy
guy was let's go in here first before we
walk outside out of the ordinary
oh I'm definitely on the other side
which is scary
this new new zones okay and now we gotta
go get that key that a little girl
kicked away from us she's running around
in here and meanwhile like big triangle
head dude it's like lumen yes I'm so
scared I got scared of my own shadow
[Music]
facts I don't like how close the cameras
in my face it's a real crash bandicoot
approached I got to get through this
[Music]
all right so I'm on the other side now I
should be able to go up this is being
played on a ps4 through PS now but it is
the ps3 version of the HD collection
wait this is the third floor jason says
scheme bring back brings back a lot of
memories didn't think anyone would play
this those forgotten miss Silent Hill 2
yeah it's it's kind of a rough game to
try and get around it because even with
the HD versions it's not like the best
way to play it and if you really want to
experience that you have to play it on a
ps2 or like an emulator legally of
course no illegal emulators anywhere
yeah it's I've got good memories of it
and I wish that I had a better way to
play it because I didn't actually get a
chance to play it how do I check my
health maybe in the menu screen I don't
remember this is red I'm bleeding
you are that the healthcare problem real
beneficial
no what the guns coming out entirely
changes his strut when he has his gun
out he's much more confident oh yeah
okay let's see if Adam see thing go the
first right now
it might be worth it to actually like
walk out grab that health kitten and
save or save and then walk out the
health kid definitely in a save first oh
wait here on the other side now it's all
not nice so I should be able to go back
through this site and when I come back
alright back to the fog
honestly we only have like 10 minutes
left so yeah it's fine it's fine
bottom floor on this side what's this
canned juice give that drink that juice
looks like can't use that here can't
can't crack open a cold one with the
boys HD version of ten shoe yeah ten
shoe was was a good time to all right
we're going back up I even liked was
attend shoes II on the 360 like it
wasn't a great 10 shoe game but it was
still a lot of fun Socorro is pretty
close to 10 shoe was it's missing just
like a little bit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
mmm steps stairs go down yeah I should
go down afraid I actually couldn't
access the second floor from this sign
so there must be something on the second
floor
okay the door would be long all these
boxes in the way we're playing this on
the ps4 through PS now but it's the ps3
HD collection version which has the
patch so it's not the best but it could
be worse so I have the fire escape key
where's the fire
clicky guys oh that's another good shout
Moodle condemns
I love condemn could also have like the
detective stuff in at 200 wow they're
having all kinds of fun over here yeah
we're gonna hide I just stay in the
closet that's just me
PNC yes
yeah I know Darryl oh no the HD
collection it's it's it's a sad thing
but what can you do I guess what pets so
the the ps3 version of the HD collection
got a patch to try and rectify a lot of
the problems that it had the Xbox
version never got the patch even though
the Xbox version is ackwards back or
actually backwards compatible on the
Xbox one there's kind of weird but
interpretive dance my favorite thing
[Music]
Oh ding we're those shots come from I
can't see with this giant mask on and my
flashlight is blaring from the closet
yeah oh god what happened
there's no way it went down like that
cyborg it is it's it's a thing but we're
at least using the original voices and
[Music]
put the gun down James James please sure
you can also play condemning Xbox games
and that might be a cool one to hit up
to yeah we're taking suggestions you
guys for sure you like a lot of people
maybe just play Zombies Ate My Neighbors
for eight days yeah they cut the scene
which is a heck of a thing
[Applause]
[Music]
all right officially lost in this tiny
room I get out of the way followed you
out okay I'm scared I don't know where
this guy is no ambush your dad you're
pretty close to probably getting God all
right I think that brings us to the end
of our stream even though I don't know
where Pyramid Head dude went it's
probably better than he's long gone
just let me unload a whole clip on his
face I can't live here
James beat Pyramid Head there from the
closet he's dead now it's all over I
beat it you guys all right you guys we
are gonna have to wrap it up there
unfortunately him um I definitely feel
like we were ramping up to the to the
goodness but I think I kind of scared
myself more than there are some good
moments there where you got scared by
your shadow yeah it was a good time
I had fun hanging out playing playing
some Silent Hill for sure yes indeed and
if you guys had fun then come on back
because for the next 8 or so days up
until you know it's very weird and
specific it's eight days of horror not
including Friday which is in community
Friday in Halloween's on Thursday so the
next Monday through Thursday and Monday
through Thursday is gonna be our eight
days of horror and you know I've been
asking you guys on Twitter what your
favorite horror games are and we off
obviously got some recommendations from
you guys in today's stream but feel free
to let us know and we are gonna be
keeping the theme alive and hopefully by
the end of these eight days I will just
have nerves of steel and I will no
longer be scared but I think that's the
fun in it anyway so yeah
you guys enjoyed please come on back the
rest of the week for some more spooky
games and have a good one
Pizza boy I miss you